[Musique]
ils seront les premiers à voyager vers
la Lune depuis 50 ans l'équipage de la
mission Artemis 2 a été dévoilé par la
NASA noter la présence d'un affreux
américain Victor Glover et d'une femme
un Cristina amocoq qui ont tous deux
déjà voyagé dans l'espace la NASA est
dans la droite ligne de sa promesse
d'envoyer la première femme et la
première personne de couleur sur la lune
pour mémoire le programme Apollo il y
avait emmené 12 hommes 12 blancs
on annonce d'édition exceptionnelle
devait
un générique d'une émission quotidienne
de BFM
le ciel sombre de Manhattan s'est
illuminé un court instant samedi soir
la foudre a frappé la flèche du One
World Trade Center et un photographe à
filmer le phénomène la vidéo
impressionnante suscite émerveillement
sur les réseaux sociaux et inquiétude de
la part d'un voisin New Yorkais l'homme
pire State Building prend des nouvelles
dans un tweet de la plus haute tour de
Manhattan
et si Jean-Claude Van Damme avait vu
juste avant tout le monde
dans 20 ans elle n'aura plus car après
avoir connu une pénurie d'essence il y a
quelques mois la France pourrait bien
prochainement manquer d'eau à en croire
certains spécialistes qui aujourd'hui
tirent la semaine d'alarme la moitié de
la population mondiale subit déjà de
graves pénurie d'eau entre sécheresse
manque de pluie et faible débit dans nos
rivières l'inquiétude de voir cette
ressource naturelle essentielle
s'épuiser gagne même du terrain au
sommet de l'État alors il est pas beau
le programme
et manifestement à danser aussi sur le
titre il était sur la piste dedans
à Saint-Malo en Bretagne où la justice a
interdit à des parents de prénommer leur
fils Hadès en référence au dieu des
Enfers la justice est basée sur quoi
pour refuser ce prénom Martin Bourdin le
parquet de Saint-Malo en fait considéré
que le prénom Hadès était un prénom je
cite contraire aux intérêts de l'enfant
puisque faisant incontestablement
référence aux yeux des morts et des
enfers
tu prépares à manger tu pues du cul sans
être vu que toute seule tu es toute
seule
ce prénom Hadès a été donné 12 fois en
2020 sont qu'aucune interdiction n'était
formulée d'autres prénoms qu'on peut
gérer un peu plus étonnant que que Hadès
sont aussi été donné validées qu'elle
est si en référence à Game of Thrones
alia Lisbonne miel pape divine divin
Steve prénom composé alpha cabinet
Tarzan Mowgli tout ça
Alpha qui
est cabinet Kaby vous êtes sûr de ça oui
tout ça ça a été validé
le journal de monde tout est faux même
la date
donc tout est faux dans le monde même la
date disait générale il faut toujours
citer le général chaque matin voilà
c'est une bon sur ce bâtiment de
plusieurs mètres de hauteur le long
d'une route le visage d'Emmanuel Macron
apparaît avec ses chiffres 49-3 dans la
même forme que la moustache d'Adolphe
Hitler une inscription indique plus bas
peinture satirique mais pour Marouane
qui passe à côté ça va trop loin je
trouve que la fresque est quand même
choquante comparé quand même Macron un
président démocrate qui était élu par le
peuple à une dictateur c'est quand même
abusif moi je pense depuis le début que
sur un canal n'ira pas au bout c'est à
la fois une intuition et une analyse
l'intuition c'est que lui-même pendant
la campagne présidentielle ne nous a pas
expliqué pourquoi il voulait continuer
un peu mécanique un peu épuisé la
fresque sera effacée dès que possible
sur l'agglomération d'Avignon il faut
même aller plus loin estime le député
Renaissance Mathieu Lefebvre évidemment
donner lieu à des pour c'est évidemment
choquant quand je vois ça je me dis où
est le débat démocratique dans ce pays
une nouvelle polémique pour le graffeur
lecto qui sera jugé en septembre pour
une autre fresque faite l'an dernier au
même endroit ça épuise le pouvoir et je
trouve qu'Emmanuel Macron nous l'a
montré et quand il a loupé les élections
législatives je me suis dit que le
quinquennat aurait du mal à aller au
bout il n'y a pas voulu nul que vous les
gens de gauche pour combattre le RN il y
a pas plus nul que vous vos phrases on
les entend depuis 30 ans c'est la gauche
qui invite rouillant à la fac de
Bordeaux
qui fait monter le RN c'est tous les
médias le Monde Mediapart l'idée qui ont
menti sur ce qui s'est passé à Sainte
Soline c'est ça qui fait monter le RN
ils ont menti
arrêtez de faire la grimace arrêter de
faire la grimaces tout ça c'est de votre
faute c'est un enfant un enfant un total
livré à ses émotions à sa colère assez
frustration il engueule tout le monde il
encourage ce qui engueule tout le monde
le contraire de nombre d'État je pars me
coucher ma fille n'est pas là enfin tu
vois je pars me coucher je regarde la
télé je pose la télécommande par terre
je vais me coucher et donc je vous
raconte la fin de l'histoire que je ne
possède pas quand ça allait fait se
déroule c'est que mon lapin il a marché
sur la télécommande et il m'a déclenché
la télé en pleine nuit et moi je suis en
train de dormir et d'un coup j'entends
deux hommes qui parlent dans mon salon
un homme qui tue une laverie en Espagne
et chope de justesse à un accident aussi
spectaculaire qu’improbable
[Musique]
la police évoque la présence dans le
séchoir d'un aérosol comme celui-ci
utilisé pour recharger les briquets
quant aux clients chanceux beaucoup
d'internautes lui conseille de jouer au
loto
mon lapin vraiment je le
déteste mon lapin ma fille elle était
pas là heureusement enfin heureusement
moi je te enfin ce qui m'a mis encore
plus en panique parce que je me dis j'ai
même pas le temps de m'enfuir pendant
qu'il s'en prenne à elle tu vois
nous inviter un duo formidable de Pékin
Express un jeune de virtuose du violon
l'oeil de Pierre les actualités de
Bertrand les infos Express le vu j'étais
assassin
installez-vous devant c'est à vous avec
le groupe jacuzzi